good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy oh [ __ ] I
haven't [ __ ] that up in a while sorry
welcome back to the toast happy Monday
hope everyone had a fabulous weekend hey
Jax how are you doing I'm darn good but
you know exactly how I'm doing since
we've been together every minute of
every day since you arrived we had the
exact same weekend we had the exact same
morning every night we had the exact
same night's sleep it's true so we are
incredibly simpatico him platico erotico
so I would say we are done pretty good
you know we had a great weekend we're
just tired okay so let's talk I have
like a list of things I want to talk
about and the first thing on my list
says stay-at-home moms so this has been
a really eye-opening weekend for me
because Zach was out of town for a
wedding so it's like me and you with
rolled Margo was here too but like let's
be honest with one another she was
totally useless
um as stated she doesn't do diapers she
doesn't do diapers so it was like really
me and you just like making sure you
know Harry was
taken care of and it was truly like an
eye-opening experience for me obviously
I don't have any children and I and of
course I respect moms I respect
stay-at-home moms whenever anyone says
like stay at home I'm hardest job in the
world I'm like yeah yeah and like I feel
like that's just something you say
um however I
I have a whole new outlook on life and I
actually know we have so many listeners
who are stay-at-home moms like I just
want to speak directly to them because
like the way you have my utmost respect
and let's lay it out like of all the
things that are like required to take
care of Harry from the time you mix up
to the time he goes to bed I probably
contributed
15 would you say that's accurate sure if
that's how you feel like if that's what
you've is that an underestimation or an
overestimation
I I think that's accurate yeah like I
like I didn't feed him but like I was
there when you fed him and like okay I
changed three diapers over the course of
like two days so how many types it's
probably like 10 total
uh I would have to count but maybe more
so it's like yeah 20
um so whatever like I'm saying I didn't
even do half like a like a parent fifty
percent I did less way less than half
um and after the first day we were like
sitting on the couch and I was literally
not okay I'm like my legs hurt my back
hurts I'm so tired I could fall asleep
for a month
um the way like you especially because
Harry's at the age where like he can't
walk or crawl so like he needs to be
transported everywhere and he's still
like could you know climb off the couch
like you need to just like constantly be
watching constantly be holding him like
your hands are constantly being used and
like the way I'm literally not okay like
I feel like on this Monday how I would
feel after the longest week of my life
like I'm so deceased and again I didn't
even do like the brunt of the work like
you were the one giving him the baths
and feeding him and like doing most of
the work but like I was being helpful um
you are I'm so tired and like the way
I've just been thinking now about how
like being a stay-at-home mom and I feel
like people look at being a stay-at-home
mom as a privilege which it is because
you have to have a partner who makes
enough money for you to be a
stay-at-home because you don't get paid
for being a stay-at-home mom which is
something we should talk about 100
um
so like it is a luxury but it's I'm
telling you like there's no job harder
there's no job harder the coal miners
could never the coal miners really could
never because like the coal miners get
to get out there they get to have me
time you know they get to go socially on
things outside of just like being a
little baby no and then beyond the baby
uh the laundry the cleaning the dishes
the non-stop just like house things like
you don't tap on your feet I'm just I'm
blown away like I'm truly blown away I'm
so glad that now you understand like why
when you have been saying in the past
like stay-at-home moms like deserve and
I always believe that but like until you
experience it you really don't know
exactly what they're doing and I wasn't
and they do never stop 100 I wasn't even
doing 50 right you guys like
stay-at-home moms you have all my love
all my respect like I'm I'm shook it was
really an eye-opening weekend for me
today's episode goes out to the stay at
home moms yeah because I've never been
here where Zach was in here so like with
Zach it's exact you me like yeah but it
was just me and you and like really you
because I was doing like the bare
minimum
lessons to it I bore witness and for
like the 15 that I did like I'm deceased
okay I know and everyone says like even
though right now it's hard to like be
carrying him all the time to always be
holding him like once they start
crawling and walking like it's even more
physical you gotta chase them yeah you
gotta chase them but that's why those
PlayStations when you can just like pop
them into something let's talk about
that let's like you just hope that he
likes it for more than 20 minutes but
really he's a 20 minute at a time kind
of guy no the way I love those what do
you call those little things you put
them in and they like they can't walk
yet but like their feet dangle and they
can like run around so there's a few
things like there are the Walkers which
they walk they say that they shouldn't
spend like more than 15 minutes at a
time in the Walkers it could make their
legs whatever you know what sometimes a
walker Saves a Life just put them in no
because I've been thinking like you know
when I have children there will be a
walker in every room in my house what I
what he was in outside is not a walker
he can't move in it it's a bouncy thing
they say those are really good oh okay
okay but I call them I don't know what
the technical term I call them
PlayStations because they sit they could
go 360 and there's toys all around yeah
okay okay well they're like heaven on
Earth because like like sometimes I just
need to get kid out of my arm like yeah
oh my God you guys I just really wanted
to start off the show on that sentiment
like I wouldn't stay at home moms
deserve to be respected and you know
what like check in on your local
stay-at-home mom she's probably not okay
totally and they're doing the most
important job in the world which is
Raising humans so you're not just like
changing diapers doing chores you're
also like responsible for
so much you guys well you're responsible
for what kind of people they are that
are entering the world right no I'm
telling you like it's the most important
work I'm a different girl than I was on
Friday like I thought I would be like a
chill weekend no no there was nothing
chill about it like nearly a moment I've
never been more excited to be locked in
the studio because they just sit here
and talk for an hour no and like about
adult things the way I I Adore Harry
this is no slight against Harry like I
would literally take several several
bullets for him
um the way I need to get away from him
um it's not normal like but then it's
that it's that gravitational pull you
know because you're away from it and you
miss him because he went down last night
I was like honestly thank God like for
real I needed a night and then this
morning like the first thing I was like
where's Harold so there is this like
gravitational pull but there's also this
gravitational push
it was just very interesting to pull on
the push yeah the push in the pull of it
all I have like a list of things I want
to talk about I have a list of things in
my head okay so I'm sure there's some
Crossovers and then I'll see if I missed
anything so there's two like business
things I want to talk about okay the
first is a special not like other girls
announcement you guys know there's three
shows left like the tour is over but up
until this point I have not filmed any
of my shows and I would like to release
a special so I've added two shows in New
York at The Gramercy theater at the
beginning of December um December 5th
and 6th it's a really small venue it's
much smaller than I'm used to because
you know I like sell I like stadiums now
um It's The Gramercy theater and you
know when you film you have to cut a
bunch of seats so it's there is really
limited seating and there is a patreon
pre-sale I do imagine that it'll sell
out in patreon pre-sale so but you could
be a part of it today if you went to
patreon.com like that's what I was
saying
um and then I'm also adding a show in
Delaware because I need like a practice
show before my New York shows that I
film and I wanted it to be local I'm
like where is a local hotspot that I
have not
infiltrated yet and justice for the
Delaware girlies so Wilmington Delaware
and then two shows in New York General
on sale starts on Friday if you're a
patreon member it'll be Wednesday at 10
A.M eastern time it's never too late to
become a patreon member patreon.com
toast and we have new content up on the
patreon I was I literally before bed
last night watching our Vlog we told you
guys on Friday that we created this like
turnt ass Vlog and we hadn't watched it
yet and then Friday night we actually
watched it and it is literally the most
unhinged piece of content we've ever
released it is a vlog of us bacon
cookies which sounds you know rather
Pleasant yeah spoiler alert it was not
pleasant like near a moment was pleasant
I never felt pleased we couldn't stop
fighting first of all we knew we were
making mistakes as we were doing it
nevertheless we persisted and
nevertheless it turned out we made
mistakes we didn't even know we were
making everyone let us know all the
things that we did wrong I will be
getting a KitchenAid mixering bowl I was
shopping for one last night they're
really expensive but they're kind of
gorgeous it's like the thing that
everyone puts on their registry and like
that's the thing did you not put one on
your registry why would I know that I
need that I had never baked a day in my
life when I just like sat in all my
Apartments until now and like it's fine
I'll get one now and now like I know
what color I want then I probably would
have gotten like a weird color now I'm
gonna get the cream one and I'm really
excited and I'm really glad for this
Vlog even though we were clowns and I
think we should be embarrassed we should
have everything that we did um it was
learning and the way we looks like let's
be real at least myself I looked good
until I showered in the final scene I
looked atrocious I hadn't even showered
and it was right when I got off the
plane and I was just looking like a big
beast
um it was a learning moment and now I
know so many new things about baking I'm
gonna have this new
um Contraption so I'm Gonna Bake even
more I will never melt butter again
otherwise you guys will come for my
throat yeah apparently that's like a
cardinal sin of baking it makes sense it
totally changes the texture
like you go from having this like thick
thing to like maybe you're melted but
you're like literally mushing it anyway
I know but baking is a science really
you can't like lessons the different
elements matter I guess what
nevertheless the Vlog is really being
lauded as some of our best work so
really really you can get access to the
pre-sale and that Vlog and like
literally 300 other episodes on
patreon.com toast 7.99 every month for
five extra episodes podcast Vlogs from
your girls and access to things before
everyone else like tickets for my New
York and Delaware shows
um the other thing I want to talk about
is what you're wearing what I'm wearing
so everyone knows the sweatshirt we
originally launched it almost four years
ago and it's our best-selling item of
all time we wear them all the time
people always ask when they're coming
back a few years ago we made them again
but still so many people our new
toasters or didn't get them then and
people always ask about them and so we
are relaunching these sweatshirts on
Thursday and I'm so excited because I
can get even more even though I have
have all of them I just want one in
every size you never know what the vibe
is so today I'm wearing size medium this
is the new this is the totally new one
so you can see like it's all fresh and
nice new color no stains um and I do
think it'll probably be our last restock
with that exact design because it is the
TMT but I still think the toaster as TMT
me too and I'm not gonna be so strict
I'm not gonna be so strict but this is
really vintage merch and it's like the
cutest comfiest thing ever so Thursday
morning 10 a.m eastern time you'll be
able to get these sweatshirts so get
them while they're hot because they're
literally the cutest thing we've ever
made and everyone has been like asking
for a restock so like alert all your
friends that like three stock is
happening and like that's right it's
Monday we're letting you know Thursday
we'll remind you all week but set your
alarms set your alarms now the other
thing I wanted to talk about was on
Saturday night me you and snitch watch
the crawdads movie we did which I didn't
wear the Crawdad sing I did not read the
book I was like didn't want to read the
book then you were like you probably
wouldn't even like it so I didn't read
it and then I didn't see the movie
because like who cares and then when we
were all out to dinner everyone was
talking about it and I was like kind of
feeling left out I'm like what is this
book even about and then you were like
would you want me to tell you like the
whole thing and I was like yeah I'm like
never gonna read the book or see the
movie then you gave me like a brief
synopsis and it sounded like the like I
was so mad like I was I wish that I had
read it or seen it like the way you
described it and just like the story in
general so not what I imagined like at
all that it would be so then I was
really lit to see the movie even though
I knew like the ending and like you know
the whole thing so we watched a movie
and I have to say I know there was mixed
reviews especially from a lot of the
people who watched the movie after they
had read the book they like hated it and
they're wrong and stupid because the
movie was literally the best movie I've
seen in years I thought it was
incredible and I just want to know like
where Reese Witherspoon found all these
hot male actors like every man in the
movie was hotter than the next I mean
Tate obsessed even that like freak Chase
so hot like even the dad
the dad he was like fake Josh Jamel he
was giving daddy you're right I totally
forgot he was hot even though he was
like a [ __ ] prick psychotic oh my God
you're right he was hot
um agreed I don't know where this
narrative came from that the car dad's
movie was not good not worth seeing and
that especially if you read the book you
wouldn't like it it I loved the book
five out of five it's an amazing book
there's a reason why it was on the New
York Times bestseller list for over 100
weeks probably still is there the movie
was incredible it was the book to a t it
was exactly how you picture the book
there was nothing that the movie did or
didn't do that should make fans of the
book upset or like felt like the movie
strayed from the Integrity of the book
it was incredible I don't know why
everybody isn't talking about this movie
watching this movie like justice for
everyone involved in the movie Justice
for Rhys Justice for Delia Owens the
author like justice for Daisy Jones who
like put her whole heart and soul into
the movie She's incredible for the
little actress who played Kaia who
deserves an Oscar the little actress who
played Kaya everyone keep an eye on her
keep an eye on her it was amazing it was
a perfect movie what's wrong with
everyone that there was even like this
conversation that it wasn't good enough
I literally don't know like it was
it was so good it was so good and then
like it was as good as the book and
Taylor had written a song for it and
like obviously I knew nothing about the
book so when I heard this song I'm like
the song is [ __ ] weird and then when
it came out in the credits I'm like this
song is perfect it's literal Perfection
Carolina
Perfection and like honestly kind of
want to live in the marsh so simple but
so complicated it's so complicated and
it was like it was emotional it was like
a love story it was so and if you've
never read the book and no one told you
the plot over dinner like you will
thoroughly enjoy it yeah Margo didn't
read the book and didn't know the plot
and when she had seen it she actually
had seen it already before we sat down
and watched it and she loved it so she
agreed to watch it again she was like
shook the first time she saw it like I
wish I had had that experience I like
love to ruin things for myself I'm such
like a [ __ ] turd like you know what
if I never described it to you never
would have wanted to watch it we could
have never gotten you to watch you know
something 1950s in the marsh no it's so
true like the way my stubbornness is
like really affecting my life
um I won't change because I am stubborn
but I'm at least self-aware enough to
acknowledge like it's one of my worst
qualities for sure yeah but I'll keep
pushing you yeah well that's the thing
like when you have a sister as great and
fabulous and such a good mom and such a
beautiful woman
um she's pushing you out of your comfort
zone and you would think like oh she's a
mom now she doesn't have time to deal
with her stubborn grown ass sister but
here's the thing she does she finds the
time yeah and I find the cases that are
worthy causes because I know you so well
yeah you do I really never pushed you to
do something that you didn't enjoy or
except for we are the brennans I've
never told you to read that that was
Mark's Choice one of the worst books
I've literally ever come across in my
life yeah I never finish it really
unremarkable what's so funny is that
month she was choosing between It
Happened One Summer and we are the
brennans and we were actually really
glad she chose we are the runners at the
time because Like It Happened One Summer
would have been a little awkward to talk
about I guess no hindsight it would have
been an iconic episode like everyone's
ahead of your time like everyone read
the book they would have listened to the
episode like who the [ __ ] cares about we
are the presents and then we are the
Brandon Tech wasn't even a decent book
it was literal trash trash
um so if you're looking for oh and the
thing I liked about we are the crawdads
we are no we are in restaurants where
the Crawdad saying is that it's the
perfect movie to watch if you're like
with a group of people and like maybe
it's like your family and someone's
older and younger like
everyone will like it like it's a
perfect movie to watch when you're in a
big group and like everyone can't agree
put it on your list for the holidays
when you're with your whole family of
what to watch that's what you should
watch and maybe then it will get the
shine that it deserves right and it's
not like awkward there's no like there
are sex scenes but there's not like
there's six parts there's no
uncomfortable yeah like it is the
perfect movie to watch when you are with
a group and like nobody can decide
everyone will like it yeah so
um it was really a great weekend very
busy but we got you know World Is Still
you know kick in so that's good because
if it was up to me like I'm literally
you know what also I realized I'm
low-key so like there are so many things
you don't think about so I'm changing
them all right I don't even tell you
this nothing happened by the way he
seems fine um changing them big Duty
huge and I uh
I flipped around to go get something I
forget what it was like I left him on
the table no can do and then when I came
back I'm like was that like a crazy
thing nothing happened but I'm like he
could have I guess like rolled off
it's um the thing is you real like
you're just coming in at month eight but
like when they're newborn you're you
typically experience everything in
stages when they're a newborn you would
never leave them on the changing table
because you're so like scared even
though they can't really move but then
you start to see how they can move and
it's like oh I can never leave so like
you never had made that connection yeah
I guess I did and it also like always
tell people when they are changing him I
used to like be really like a helicopter
parent would be like don't leave him on
don't leave him unattended and people
are like are you crazy I would never do
that so I stopped it's like an instinct
thing I guess that like I totally missed
yeah I was like yeah you'll be fine bye
yeah but he was fine he was totally fine
and then like another thing like his
neck is just so crazy it's like when I
put him down one night like it's hard to
like lean over the crib especially a big
breasted woman
um so I like plopped him down like his
head
but onto the mattress but I was like I
guess that was like a little rub it's
onto the mattress so it's fine yeah his
head is just wild he like when I woke
when I picked him up one morning he
literally like threw his head into my
nose I'm Marcia Brady like oh crap my
nose like literally I thought I broke my
nose you know he bangs his head into
like everyone so the mattress is nothing
yeah okay no so he's totally fine like
for sure yeah it wasn't my fault but
like but typically everything happens in
stages so you start to like use when
he's a newborn you're always holding of
course and then you know as he gets
older and more grown you realize the
changes that are happening so like and I
can't stress how much I love rolled but
like I need to write today like for real
like I need to go out to lunch and like
maybe we're going to the mall like I
need a minute you know but I love him
endlessly even more every day you know
and like if we go to the mall like we're
gonna miss him so yeah like Zach is here
and like thank God yeah
so it was a great weekend hope everyone
um listening had a great weekend whether
it was filled with Bebes or liquor
whatever happy for you happy for you we
also watched House of the Dragon which
will be recapping at the end of the
episode you want to know how busy the
weekend was I didn't even get to finish
my show I have two episodes left same as
I had last week and I didn't get a
moment to watch because when I got into
bed at like 10 30. deceased I could go
to sleep yeah no that's that's tough I
didn't watch a lot of TV because my room
doesn't have a TV until last night until
last night I Zach finally got home and I
made him bring this TV from like one of
the guest rooms upstairs I couldn't
carry it by myself but I also ordered
myself a TV because I don't want to be
like I spend a lot of time here I want
to be like an imposition I've been
meaning to bring that TV down for you
but the times that you spent here you
actually thought it was nice that you
didn't have a TV because you read so
much yeah you must not be enjoying your
book I'm not so that's why you needed a
TV no also like I just like I need a TV
like it's time okay I just want you know
in the past you actually remarked about
how you kind of liked not having one oh
I don't remember otherwise in the last
three I could have brought it down at
any point for you it's funny it doesn't
sound like something I would say but
that's why it was so shocking that you
said it so I was just like I hit my
limit like I needed a [ __ ] TV so we
got that TV down and I also ordered
myself a new TV because like I don't
want to be stealing TVs from your other
rooms no one's in there so when my new
TV and also like I want the new one like
not to be a brat so when the new one
comes I'll give Margo because Margo's
room also doesn't have I'll give Margo
this TV and she'll be grateful she
better Ray so
um now I'm feeling like I'll probably
never leave like now I have a TV yeah
like I got everything I need you never
need to leave like Bryce and Thrice are
having the time of their life and miss
nolia and Ben finally got here last
night right and the boys were all
playing outside yesterday it was the
cutest thing it was a great weekend
really beautiful weather now that it's
October I have to say like I can see how
someone lives here because when my ass
was here for two weeks in August I swear
to God like I it was actually the pits
of hell it was so [ __ ] hot just
to do anything like walking Theo was
horrendous I gotta have to shower every
time I walked him and now it's just
simply delightful like there's a cool
breeze I've been wearing leggings and a
sweater every day and like yeah I'm a
little warm but my legs just aren't like
ready for you know you know what you
haven't done yet swim that's how busy
you've been now you see how I've never
been in my pool without you
I
remember
so
um
I'm ready are you oh now you're ready
okay yeah I feel like we spoke about
everything like I was creating a list
all weekend because like I was just
having these like you know existential
thoughts about life and motherhood look
at you I'm a mother of this like no
drama is this not
helping like you feel like that's
something I want to do even sooner it's
not drawing me in even though like there
are moments you know like when I put him
down where I'm literally sobbing like
into his you know cookie onesie
it definitely doesn't make me want to do
it sooner if anything it's making me
more motivated to
um work really hard and have success so
that I can hire a lot of help honestly
like I I'm just gonna acknowledge like
that's the mom I'm gonna be like it's I
have a low threshold and you have like a
very high threshold for like torture
um I do not like once like
how like I reach my limit like I had to
walk out of the room like with Harry and
like you obviously can't do that so I
just I need to
um like have enormous success so I can
have a staff of people the thing is you
really build up to the threshold of
torture like when I think about how I
used to be I used to be the laziest
[ __ ] alive especially on the weekends I
could sleep till two and then lay in bed
all day and watch TV and be too tired to
go out to dinner yeah you know but now
like I'm up and then even when he takes
a nap like there's dishes there's
laundry right there's that and like you
just
you build up to it yeah I don't really
want to so I'm going to be hiring staff
like that I'm gonna be that saying
you're capable of more than anything no
I know I mean especially if I'm like
shove a kid out of my vision like I know
I'm gonna be like super mom and like I'm
gonna watch this back and be like haha
and I'm gonna be doing everything myself
scrubbing the floors yeah I'm gonna be
like I'm gonna be like a mama four with
big new veneers and like literally no I
won't let anyone help I'm like Ben get
out of no staff no nanny like no I know
like it's like you say things and then
you become a mom and like you do things
differently but like I'm I just have a
really strong feeling I'm gonna be a mom
with staff like I hope oh my God God
willing I should be so lucky it's such a
privilege like so that's why like
everyone share this podcast
share with your friends like I need a
nanny you know yeah okay love that for
you
um you ready Devin I'm ready to dive in
to the past five stories that you need
to know today
and today's episode is brought to you by
solostove you know summer gets all the
excitement but nothing beats The Great
Outdoors during the fall that's what we
were just saying it's truly Heavenly
make the most of your outdoor time this
season with solo stoves smokeless
portable fire pits that are easy to set
up and to clean so if you don't have um
like a backyard with like an official
fire pit because it's a crazy expensive
so let's show this kind of everything
because first of all it's a really
affordable way to have like a fire pit
like a really cute vibe in your backyard
but it's also portable so if you go on
lots of Vacations or you'd like to Camp
or hike or like rent houses in the
mountains with your friends you just
throw it in your trunk and it's like so
easy to just pull out and start a fire
and the way it's built is like making
the most premium fires because the way
that the titanium I'll explain hang on
so it's a stainless steel construction
and it is designed to regulate airflow
and burn more efficiently so you're not
like sitting in front of a fire with
tears coming out of your eyes because
the smoke is in your eyes and you're
like this is great isn't it like I love
my fire no so let's hope it's here I'd
like to give you a premium fire and a
premium experience there's a little
smoke and you'll literally wonder how
there's so much fire it is the perfect
Catalyst for getting outside spending
more time with friends and family and
build lasting memories around the solo
Stove fire pit they're brilliantly
engineered to be easy to use and they're
built to last super easy to light just a
few bits of starter is required and then
your fire will be blazing in minutes
solo stove is so confident that you'll
love their product that they are
offering a lifetime warranty and a
30-day free return policy you can use
promo code toast at solost.com for an
extra 10 off because they're having
their big solo stove fall event so go
you'll get the best price on their
website and then use promo code toast
for an extra 10 off so the website is
solostove.com promo code toast for ten
dollars off on top of the already great
fall event deals the fall event ends
November 10th so get it done because
this is like the best time of year to be
having a fire
um today's episode is also brought to
you by ZipRecruiter I know we have a lot
of toasters who are business owners
girlies who perhaps could be looking for
people to hire you know you're expanding
um that's why you should check out
ZipRecruiter zip recruiter can help you
find qualified candidates fast and you
can try it for free when you go to
ziprecruiter.com toast so whether you
need to hire a civil engineer in New
York a pediatric nurse in Nebraska an
attorney in Colorado a mascot in
Missouri I feel like that's going to be
like the name of my like third and final
book the mascot for Missouri and it'll
kind of be like this rom-com okay
whatever we'll we'll spitball it you
take off your mascot helmet everyone
realizes she's beautiful you know so
whatever whether you're looking for an
accountant to a zoologist or everything
in between zip recruiters matching
technology finds people with the right
experience for your job and presents
them to you then you can invite your top
choices to apply it's so effective that
four out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day you could try it
now for free at this exclusive link
ziprecruiter.com toast once again that's
ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t-z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r.com
slash toast ZipRecruiter the smartest
way to hire it truly is a smart best way
to hire and sometimes it can be hard to
find oh 100 just as you were stating
you'll be using zip recruiter 100
great great platform highly recommend it
I've been working for a while yeah are
you ready for our first story we've got
some good stories today yeah okay first
up the nanny is still speaking out about
Olivia and Jason and though we're
ignoring most of the stuff especially as
it pertains to the children in the
marriage and then because we don't do
that like after spending the weekend
with Harry like you think like one thing
about me I respect children but the
nanny said that Flo was sleeping with
Harry Styles before Olivia and Harry got
together and suddenly I'm I'm back in
I'm back in yeah you know that Nanny she
has a way of pulling you in
and I will say though there was like a
lot of stuff um that allegedly like
Olivia and Jason did to her and like
she's disgruntled for a reason whether
it was about like docking her pay or
firing her without you know notice and
being like really inappropriate like
with just like getting her involved in
their family stuff and like none of that
is okay none of that for me is
justifiable in exploiting someone's
personal life someone that you worked
for someone that you probably signed an
NDA for and somebody who you were in
charge of taking care of their kids but
it is important to admit like she's
she's a grudge like for a good reason
for sure but I agree that it's that's
not enough how you retaliate is going to
the press and sharing people's private
details yeah but in the final part of
her exclusive interview with the Daily
Mail Olivia Wilde's former Nanny reveals
the extraordinary claim of the romance
between Florence Pugh and Harry Styles
she said Olivia told Jason Sudeikis
about Flo allegedly sleeping with the
singer and then Jason told the nanny
just before the premiere of don't worry
darling the nanny told Flo about the
claim the exchange set off of falling
out between the two women and finally
explained in the notoriously Frosty
premiere of the film in Venice so no
I mean that was my first guess you know
like she was having this moment with him
and then Olivia Wilde swooped in yeah I
don't know either
oh totally random it just reminded me of
this you know that book the idea of you
that you were just telling me to read
you know they're making it into a movie
with Anne Hathaway I told you that when
I told you to read it
and the pictures that came out like a
few days ago and they I didn't read the
book but based on what I know about the
book it looks really good right the book
is written off of a fan fiction of
somebody who like started fan fiction
online about Harry Styles about this
like older woman who goes to Harry
Styles concert and Harry like falls in
love with her and everybody's been
saying like Olivia Wilde and Harry
Styles is that book oh have they been
saying that yeah okay because I was
thinking that too I thought maybe I had
like an original idea for once no
because it's literally about Harry
Styles right okay Styles
um I don't know if I necessary I don't
know for some reason and I know nothing
about Florence Pew like I'm not even
like a huge fan of her work I didn't
really know her before don't worry
darling I just don't get the vibe that
she's like the kind of girl like let's
say this did happen like I don't think
she's the kind of girl who would
sacrifice like her working reputation
over a boy do you know what I mean like
not showing up to premieres and like
making drama I don't know I feel like a
lot of the other things we've heard
about why Florence is disgruntled and
like mad at Olivia I feel like that is
more in line with the character I
believe she has but I don't know her
character I obviously don't know her
personally and I'm not even like a huge
follower I think that she wouldn't do
all all of that just because of a boy
but I think that the way Olivia acted
like being unprofessional not showing up
to set like Florence feeling like she
had to be the director at times
Florence is probably acting the way that
she's acting because of that part you
know but if Olivia and Harry had gotten
together and Olivia you would never have
known the difference and everything was
really professional and above board then
I don't think Florence would have cared
or would act like this and maybe she
would be heartbroken a little bit right
but I think she would have been
professional but I think she feels that
Olivia Wilde started the
unprofessionalism I do feel that way and
like I don't know I just I feel like
over the years there's been like I just
remember like as a kid like looking at
all those tabloid magazines like Nanny's
always speaking out there's like every
couple of years there's like a crazy
Nanny situation
um and if you would have told me that
the next Nanny situation is going to be
Olivia Wilde and Jason stake it's like
when they were together I would not have
believed you because they were like
anything but messy they were like so
solid for so long yeah and I'm still
having a hard time adjusting to like
putting them in my like messy category
yeah you know because for me they're
like they've kind of been like Staples
like No And it's weird because like now
Harry's falling into the messy category
and like we know nothing about his his
personal life and he's like so above
this like it's really they all are
honestly yeah this is like some reality
TV trash yeah also the nanny said that
she brought uh Olivia's daughter to set
because she's apparently in the movie oh
and or like has a little Cameo and
that's when she saw that like Olivia
acting like she'd never seen her act she
said Olivia told Jason a couple weeks
after Harry started that flow was
[ __ ] Harry and she had a boyfriend
but was [ __ ] Harry then Olivia
started seeing Harry herself it was all
very quick a lot of people don't know
that she said that the seemingly jealous
Olivia was giddy around Harry Styles on
set in October 2020 saying the first
time I noticed anything was when I took
her daughter out to be in the movie
Olivia was acting Giddy and she was
putting her face in her hands and saying
she couldn't believe he was so young I
didn't know who Harry Styles was at that
time and I thought wow I've never seen
her like that okay well
um you don't know who Harry Styles is
but
you would literally work for like a
celebrity couple so you're familiar with
celebrity culture it's not like you live
under a rock like you live in L.A
I actually don't think there's like a
single leaving living breathing human
person who lives in L.A who doesn't know
where Harry Styles in October 2020 right
no I'm I'm I'm suspicious of of her that
that my radar just went off yeah so
[ __ ] weird but that's what she's
saying okay well
um
I don't know
either you have to believe everything
this nanny says or none of it right
and I'm kind of leaning towards
everything well it's just because Olivia
kind of validated with the salad
dressing thing like there was a thing
about salad and then she posted the
recipe as a joke but it's like okay so
there was a salad so there's truth to it
yeah no by the way amazing call
okay well I guess we're believing it all
then no I don't know I'm not believing
any of it but I just do I'll keep it on
file yeah I'd like to knock it the
narrative for me Isn't that Flo is upset
because she was hooking up with Harry
it's like maybe she was let's not make
it flow like the villain and all this
like being like a caddy like teenager I
just I really want to wash my hands of
this situation it's making me hate every
single person involved except for flow
but it's like it's definitely making me
be like Harry like come on yeah and it's
just I don't there's so many things
going on I don't know what to believe
and I don't like being in this place of
like having to choose sides and based on
nothing because people I don't [ __ ]
know whose word am I gonna take he said
she's my truth is truth my truth is
truth that's the truth
wishing everyone the best truly like
I've had enough truly uh speaking of my
truth his truth Travis Scott is denying
cheating on Kylie Jenner with rumored X
rojian Carr Travis Scott picked up the
phone to shut down claims he hung out
with his rumored ex amid his
relationship with Kylie in response to
the Instagram models alleged proof that
the two were recently on the same set of
one of his Productions their opportunity
to his Instagram story late Saturday to
address the quote weird [ __ ] going on
quote an Uninvited person with sneaking
photos on what was supposed to be a
closed set while I was directing a video
I don't know this person I've never been
with this person he then seemingly asked
car directly to stop with the continuous
cyber games in the fictional
storytelling
where like she's out here sharing like
photos that she deems as proof that she
not only has had a relationship with
Travis in the past but like it's still
going on and that like they're together
and in love and he's pretending he
doesn't know her and it's all like to
protect Kylie
um
and like for some reason this is just
like a pop culture story especially when
related to the Kardashians they're like
I um
like don't care like first of all
Kylie's relationship with Travis is like
so private and so weird and so on and so
off like I never know what's going on
with them and like honestly like I I
truly don't care like sometimes I forget
that Kylie has a man I'm always sitting
here thinking like who should Kylie date
like you know meanwhile she's married
right like it's so
they're like to me they're like a
non-couple like I can't explain it yeah
I actually think I agree with that in
general and I don't know what Travis
does in his life I don't think that he
was hooking up with this person when she
said that he was because I I don't think
he would address it because because it
would draw attention to nobody cares and
I feel like nobody was talking about it
I didn't know this person before and I
feel like he felt good about coming out
and being like this person's lying
because this is telling the truth right
I mean also I think it must be nice for
Travis to be involved in some sort of
tabloid drama that's not about you know
the death of his fans like for real
because that's for me like that's you
know top of Mind constantly because I'm
the type of girl who doesn't forget no I
don't forget the lawsuits are ongoing
and it hasn't even been a year and so
yeah if you were with this girl or that
girl like like I don't care like to me
there's more pressing matters when it
comes to the topic of conversation of
Travis Scott and I also feel like Kylie
whatever however it comes to their
relationship if he was dating this girl
at that time like
I feel like either that means him and
Kylie were together or him and Kylie
have an understanding some sort of
understanding but I also feel like him
and Kylie are actually solid and he
wasn't with this girl yeah
it's so it's like the weirdest part of
Kylie's like brand that like she like
has this like non-boyfriend boyfriend
husband man one of the biggest stars in
the world yeah no it's like I always I'm
out here forever and they operate like
so separately separately I'm always out
here forgetting that Kylie's in a
relationship like
I have to be reminded of it constantly
and she's always posting like loved up
stuff right always no but like it
doesn't register for me no me neither is
that weird like
it's not real in my mind
no it's pretty real they have two kids
together no I know like I get it but in
my mind it just it does same kind of the
word stanchion doesn't register ever for
you like this relationship like does not
get cemented in my brain I feel that way
about other celebrities too where it's
like you could tell me again and again
that they're together and I'll it'll be
news to me every time yeah it's like no
it's just like oh right right right
right like totally forgot yeah like I'm
just not thinking about these two ever
like she has proof he has proof I agree
that like the fact that he's addressing
it makes me just inclined to believe him
um especially because it was like a
nothing burger like I don't know if he
would have even heard about it I think
girls all the time claim that there was
a person or that person right
and I just think like you know
celebrities are like now like super
um
like careful I feel like there was like
a time period like with social media and
texting like people are getting really
messy and like all this proof was coming
out because people would like [ __ ]
celebrities and then just like use it
for clout I mean now I feel like
celebrities like are much more careful
much more like I know most celebrities
don't have even um
like their iCloud turned on because
they're like so paranoid of like people
finding whatever it is that they're up
to so people are much you know tighter
about that now so none of the proof that
I saw was like
full like 100 convincing to me yeah the
only thing that's weird is like this
girl's his rumored ex but he says he's
never met her doesn't know her
Merriam-Webster defines stalker for me
to find X you have to know him right no
like what is the history with this girl
that's a good place to start yeah
but again again like I truly like like
truly in my bones like I don't care like
I don't care like I would rather talk
about Kylie Cosmetics what do you want
to say
Kylie Cosmetics is not doing enough
no I I agree because even though I love
like I just use the lip liner today
um aside from the lip products like I
feel like Kylie cosmetics and it
definitely feel like Kylie Cosmetics is
in an unfair position because they're
just like people will make videos and
like reviews like dragging it just
because like that [ __ ] gets traction so
like it has more negative reviews than I
think a typical brand I'm not worried
about the reviews but I'm just talking
about like from uh Innovation yeah the
beauty industry is so interesting like
it's actually like a a unique time like
I feel like a lot of Beauty Brands are
like actually closing down like Becca
just closed down bite Beauties closing
down like I feel like there's it's
becoming really oversaturated and with
all these like big celebrity brands that
are really doing very well there's not
enough space for everyone like
eventually like brands are gonna have to
shut down and I feel like once Kylie
sold like 51 of the company to Cody like
everyone kind of stopped trying
um and like she does these collections
like at first it was really cool like
the Grinch Christmas one but now it's
like the same thing over and over she's
like a Batman one now and it's like just
basically licensing like a popular brand
like making an eye shadow palette out of
it and like it's not very Innovative and
the products like are fine but they're
like at a higher price point because
you're paying for like the Kylie name
and I don't know I just feel like there
was a timer like every time they dropped
it was like what is it what is it like
what's a new product what is the the
aesthetic what brand is she collabing
with and now it's just like oh great
like another Marvel like it's just like
mare yeah I feel that for me like I
don't need novelty products from Kylie
Cosmetics it's weirdly like where I go
for like my staple lip colors and I
think that she should spend more time
on that front like putting together
collections of like every day not just
these like kitchen Collectibles yeah
like because I do need some new fresh
lip colors I love the ones that I have
from her but I don't know what I mean
next and I need Kylie to tell me because
I trust her for lips period agreed and I
haven't left yet and maybe if I find
like a different brand that's answering
my lip needs then I would be gone yeah
but I'm still here and I'm still I'm
waiting and I'm willing yeah I think
they just need to step it up a little
bit and I think that they need to invest
more in everyday staple type things not
these like collections that are like
kind of outrageous yeah I feel like
everybody's moved on from that a little
bit you know it's like a very 2018 star
yeah like it's very like YouTube era
where like KitKat did a collab with wet
and wild they're like Care Bears X color
pop like it's just like I feel like
people are over it and I think I feel
like makeup's changing a little bit like
it's much more like Tilbury like natural
aesthetic exactly natural exactly not
like we're putting you know purple
Picasso starry nights on our Island no
it's true we like the the beauty
standard is actually like really much
more toned down now it's like very
natural very do that's why Charlotte
Tilbury has become like overnight the
biggest makeup brand period because like
they don't do crazy colors like all
their eyeshadows are very natural and
nude and they're just like contour and
dewy skin and sparkles so Kylie feels
like a little stuck in the past with the
cosmetics and what the hell is going on
with kkw beauty I know and like what
about those of us who have come to rely
so heavily on the body Foundation like
where are we supposed to get it I feel
like the body foundations like really
could be like kin I agree because it's
like a skekin product I just think
whatever happens with kkwbd fine but we
need body Foundation yeah no and like
people especially makeup artists like
loved loved loved the kkw lipsticks and
lip liners like way more than Kylie's
like it was like a real Staple in the
beauty community and people are really
mad especially if they come back they
might not have the same shade or the
same formula yeah so people are really
nervous and it's been a long time yeah I
don't know what's going on I don't think
she needs to bring it back actually
period period wow she's got a lot going
on but also she's not kkw so that is the
big thing yeah but like
I feel like it was I don't know I just I
feel like she could move on and Jessica
kin right and she has a million other
things yep okay next story Ellen
Degeneres shows star Sophia Grace
reveals that she's pregnant expecting
her first baby and if that doesn't make
you feel old I don't know what will but
what might make you feel younger is that
she is 19. okay so like this is the
thing like I think everyone had their
own reaction to this like especially
People of Our Generation being like damn
I feel old for me I was like [ __ ]
because I'm already feeling like you
know against the clock like I'm 28 like
I don't have kids and like I want to
have kids like literally not right now
like it's something that like plagues me
when I go to bed every night and it's
like this [ __ ] Sophia Grace is
out here having kids showing me up like
for me not to make everything about me
but like this was really hard for me I'm
so sorry for you it was tough but I'm
happy for Sofia because she revealed and
discussed her pregnancy in a YouTube
blog where she admitted that she thought
some of her fans were going to be very
shocked at the news and that she had
four months left to go in her pregnancy
Journey oh so she waited a long time to
tell everyone yeah she said I'm here to
tell you guys that I'm pregnant so I'm
21 weeks today and the reason why I left
did so long is because I always want to
make sure that everything is completely
fine and that everything's safe she said
that everything was fine following her
recent 20-week ultrasound and that she
was too shocked when she first found out
about her pregnancy and now she's used
to it and she's super super happy about
is she in a relationship
um it's not clear from what I've seen
but I feel like yes I could probably
just look at her Instagram I was
genuinely shocked by this like well it's
nice that her sister is going to be an
Auntie Rosie cousin so Antoine's removed
Rosie's her cousin what they're not
sisters no
like for me like yeah of course this
makes me feel old but like when I saw a
picture of the two of them growing up
and being like thoughts like that was
more shocking and like more making me
feel old than the pregnancy honestly yes
I agree especially just because once you
find out she's 19 it's like oh we
already digested that I'm okay with that
yeah it's been 10 years it feels like 10
years there's this word on Tick Tock I
cannot remember
[ __ ] it's really bothering me like the
it's like a word in Britain like UK
culture that they describe um
like a certain look and like Sophia
Grace like has that look I think it's
called like Chaz and there's like a a
tick tock sound Associated if you don't
know me I'm m to the B retro maybe you
better watch it Sophie you think you're
only a girl out here doing Grom it's
like a makeup look like thick eyebrows
um lots of bronzer like poofy hair I
don't know what the word is does anybody
know what I'm talking about
you have to if you're like a tick tock
early it's like Chaz Chad chav chav yes
Chad like she's a chav like I don't know
anything about British culture like I
might be wrong but like I think she's a
Chad okay so and so when I first saw a
picture of her grown-up like looking
like a chav I was like oh my God like
that made me feel old a little bit more
than this because once I realized she
was 19 I'm like oh it's not like she's
at like a classic age for having
children like 19 is a little young yeah
um so it didn't make me feel that old
honestly like I felt good about it like
At first I was like [ __ ] is she like 24
kill me right but she's 19 so right and
I'm happy for her and she seems really
happy she seems really like happy and
confident in her choice and like we
respect
choices you know and we respect mothers
right and we expect expecting mamas we
expect expecting we respect expect
that's a mouthful we respect expecting
mamas so wishing her the best in her
pregnancy and a lifetime of happiness
with her and her future child truly
always yeah
are you ready for our next story a
little controversy for Meghan Markle
yeah
so former brief we've been talking so
much about Meghan Markle she's been like
in the press a lot yeah well she's
always in the Press now once a week from
her new show where she's addressing
archetypes and she did like two
back-to-back big interviews variety this
this controversy is from variety no this
so there's two kinds this deal or no
deal is from bimbo which was Paris
Hilton's episode yeah but what we're
talking about is from variety we're
about to talk about bimbo first and then
you're gonna tell me about that video Oh
I thought we were talking about the
variety okay we will get to it because
so everybody what is she meant for
getting in trouble for now so the former
briefcase models from dealer No Deal are
ripping her claims of being objectified
objectified oh the other women have
spoken the other women have spoken
Meghan Markle is receiving criticism for
her claims of feeling objectified during
her time as a briefcase model on dealer
no deal in addition to Media backlash
former models of the popular game show
are slamming The Duchess for arguing
that they were treated like bimbos one
former dealer No Deal model Patricia
Cara said quote everyone on the show
knew their role knew the image
auditioned volunteered and accepted the
job I do not share her experience at all
I never felt objective side
um also during her episode she revealed
that there had been different Beauty
stations to prepare for the game show
yeah including a section where you can
add padding in your bra
the former dealer No Deal model Patricia
Cara said there's no truth to the
padding station and all the years I
worked on the show that never existed
um another dealer No Deal model said
instead of ever feeling like a bimbo I
knew working along alongside such
wonderful people like Howie Mandel would
only lead to bigger and better things
for me and that former model said that
it hasn't just been her looks that
landed her the job but her positive
nature personality and overall work
ethic you know what I feel like
um
honestly I feel like everyone and not to
sound like Crystal Kung makeup like
everyone when it comes to this deal or
no deal thing like is telling their
truth like I think you know you're gonna
take that job and
I think it's very clear when you
audition and sign up like you are there
because you're a beautiful woman like
you're not your brain isn't opening the
suitcase uh your hands and your body is
so it sounds like some of those women
like went into it with like realistic
expectations and like wanted to get the
good out of it and like have a positive
attitude and it sounds like Megan went
into it like
a little blind even though like that's
like becoming a stripper and being mad
that people are looking at your boobs
like it's part of the job so to be to be
objectified in a sense so Megan coming
away with that experience like okay it's
very possible that she felt objectified
but like
that's literally the job and I think
that's what these women are saying like
you can look at it like we all went into
it knowing like we were being used
because we're beautiful women so you can
look at it from a negative space book we
chose that and like there were really
good things that happened from it too
like being in that industry if you're a
model I think it's like a great platform
for you so I think this is all about
like attitude yeah and it sounds like
these women are like
toxically positive and and Reagan is
looking at it from like a like a toxic
and negative point of view I think yeah
it's also about perspective like you're
standing up there opening briefcases are
you happy to be doing that or that's not
the work that you want to be doing and
you want more right like I think maybe
some women are just like really grateful
for the job and like
to have their bills paid and now like
Megan obviously became a princess
afterwards so like it's easy to look
down on it when you've come so far but I
didn't recognize any of those people's
names like I think for them it was a job
and like they're just grateful for the
job for sure especially as like a woman
in Hollywood like you could have a job
that's so [ __ ] toxic and bad to the
fact that like there are women who come
forward and say like yeah we were all
wearing little dresses but like we felt
respected there was no nefarious there
was no it's Hollywood like you know what
could happen so honestly I think they're
probably just grateful that they got
like a paying job that puts you in Sag
that you get benefits for that um
you're not [ __ ] traumatized by I
don't think a lot of women can say that
right so it sounds like it's just about
perspective you're right yes but there
either was a padding station or there
wasn't right no that's that's true yeah
um I'll need to speak to some more
models before I come to a decision well
the thing that I thought we were going
to talk about is this Tick Tock that's
gone viral of Megan like so she did this
big interview with variety and they did
like video content and of course they
started clipping it for tick tock
because you know if you want to be
anyone you need vertical video that's
why the toast is the biggest podcast on
the planet
um and this clip like that was pretty um
like you would watch it it's like pretty
innocuous but like
it's been dissected to filth on Tick
Tock because she was asked like what are
you and Harry what TV are you guys
watching the question is what do you
guys watch what's the TV that you're
watching so we get like the most
long-winded answer and it's just like
it's full of like it's it's giving it's
giving cringe like she goes you know
after we put the kids down and after
we've played a little Wordle and maybe
you know done 10 or 15 minutes of my
Duolingo because you know I took French
I've decided to relearn it because I
took four years of it in high school but
it's just completely left my brain and I
I want to relearn it so I'm doing
Duolingo after all that
um we'll turn if we TV if we turn the TV
on which is you know such a rare
occurrence like it's not like a frequent
thing but if we turn the TV on we like
really love to watch you know really
compelling storytelling and you know
White Lotus is a great example of that
so all of that just to say they're
watching White Lotus and like I just
hate like I hate to like really be like
a negative nitpicker when it comes to
Meghan Markle because she gets a lot of
that but like people who like look down
on people who watch TV a lot like if it
was giving like a little like holier
than that like we never watch TV I'm
gonna do my word games it's such a
humble bag like they asked you what TV
shows you like and you're talking about
your high school French experience like
answer the question just say White Lotus
it was a very long way of saying it was
word salad it was a long way of saying
the White Lotus but like like you know
so humble braggy about all the other
things that you do like being an
intellect learning a new language never
watching TV I appreciate storytelling
yeah like it was just free watching yeah
it was very it was patronizing and so
people are picking it apart on Tick Tock
which honestly has been like funny like
sorry it has been yeah also
um so you're watching the White Lotus
okay cool
our fifth Story is actually about white
light has been speaking of tick tock
clips that we were watching this weekend
that we meant to watch the full
interview I think we should talk about
um what we saw no for sure but like we
okay so for some reason I ended up on
this like weird side of tick tock I
think there was like a the thing is I'm
not really familiar with Joe Rogan
culture and like I'm not I don't listen
to his podcast every day to know like
what the like the t is but he did an
episode with Eliza Schlesinger who was
out promoting her new book in a new
Netflix special she's a female comic um
I don't have to say like female comic
she's a comic
um
right I ended up on this like weird side
of tick tock where people were like
breaking down her interview with Joe
Rogan and like clipping out something
like the cringy [ __ ] that she said and
like analyzing like whether Joe liked
her and like neither one of them
promoted the episode so then I fell down
this [ __ ] Rabbit Hole of like wanting
to know what's going on between Elijah
Schlesinger and Joe Rogan and I then of
course had to get Jackie involved and at
first she was like who cares but then
like once you started watching you saw
that there's something there there's
something there so so many times this
weekend we sat down to watch the whole
episode so we could judge for ourselves
people were saying that Joe was like
visibly annoyed with Eliza and like well
some of the clips that we saw like some
of the stuff she was saying was like
positively Dreadful like so reductive
and
uninformed you know she was like
literally like make like this video she
was out here being like you know I was
getting
um medical treatment in Sweden or
something like a place where they have
Universal socialized health care so like
everyone is in like if Beyonce walks in
it doesn't matter like we're all the
same so she was saying like I'm a
celebrity like I want special treatment
she said her husband was waiting a
really really long time and they like
weren't giving him any attention and so
she was like well she asked the person
like what if like Beyonce came in here
like what would you do there's obviously
a way to get better trees
I want to pay for it she said I'm a
celebrity she did say that and so then
Joe was like you asked them it was she
was just like bragging it was so cringe
it was like she they were just so we
wanted to watch so we wanted to watch it
but we sat down 45 times and then Harry
like we literally never watched past the
first two minutes so it's not I don't
want to dive in but like I and then I
was reading things on Twitter that you
were sending me like there is something
weird going on because neither Joe
didn't promote the episode which is like
kind of crazy and neither Eliza like for
Joe like you're not gonna promote your
own podcast and for realize it's like
you're going on the biggest podcast in
the world and you're not gonna promote
there's there's something that they both
had a terrible time they both had a
terrible time like towards the end it
was like he was like I cannot talk to
this woman anymore and she was like
feeling so uncomfortable like Joe
obviously doesn't want to talk to me
anymore like I I need to watch the
episode before I can give like a full
decree but that's the rabbit hole we
went down this weekend I think it's
gonna be painful to watch I know because
like there's two comedians who watch an
awkward interview of two people not just
like you know 10 minutes on Jimmy Kimmel
like I think it's two hours two hours
and by the way that's short for him
which goes to show that he was done not
having fun but it was like the clips
that I've seen so again this is only
coming from the POV of someone who's
seen probably a collective eight minutes
and clips like every time she was they
were talking about like political or
social issues and it's clear like they
are not agreeing on much but I think Joe
wanted to give her the space to speak
she was um like every time she would
like talk about like a statistic or a
specific story like he would have his
guy you know like be Googling it right
like he was like not believing anything
think she was saying I need to watch it
anymore something as innocuous as Dwayne
Johnson's cheat meals right yeah yeah
she was talking about how like I think
she was trying to make it like a funny
bit yeah which just like it was kind of
like a like a like not super funny and
she was just like trying to say like a
funny thing
um he was like oh really Jamie pull it
up and they're like pulling up some of
the Rock's Instagram posts of his cheat
Day meal so she was just basically
making a joke it's like your cheat day
like you're still having like protein
powder pancakes it's not like you know
chocolate chip pancakes
um it was just like a like a really
offhand like not that funny thing and he
like made it a 45 minute conversation
like it was I need to watch the full
episode but if anybody knows like what
we're talking about like you have extra
Insight like please share it sound off
in the comments because we're so curious
like what is going on between Eliza
Schlesinger and Joe Rogan yeah no I
think it just was I mean not every he
does so many episodes as we saw when we
were trying to find this episode was
from four days ago we go to his thing
there's already five episodes five new
episodes for me right and like maybe
he's trying to bury it so many different
people you're not gonna click with
everyone no you're not gonna get two
Comics like I don't know I'm sure that's
why he had her to begin with it's like
okay she's a comedian and she's been on
before she's been on before yeah episode
like 400 and now he's on up to like
almost 2 000 so like it must have been
two years ago
yeah so it's just it's just like a funny
thing that we're like kind of now
obsessed with so if anyone has any good
like Insider memes they want to share
like let us know and they do hope we
find the time yeah I need to watch an
episode
Fifth and final story
White Lotus premiered to
um is it HBO Max or HBO HBO is HBO Max
no like are they putting on the whole
season or is it episode by episode
episode by episode
then
I don't remember because last time I
watched I think like it's happened
Episode by episode no no but I'm saying
did they ever put a whole season yeah
when I watch check size of cowgirls it
was HBO Max was it done I don't think so
because that was relatively early I
didn't think there was a difference oh
that's a good question
I think HBO Max is where you can watch
all HBO on demand and not have to have
the channel but I feel like there are
some shows that are exclusively HBO math
like what I thought sex lives of cooking
girls maybe we were just late to
watching it right no that's I think I'm
late to a lot of [ __ ] so all the
episodes are already out okay well White
Lotus premieres on HBO on October
October 30th and takes place in Sicily
Italy and follow us a new a new cast of
well-heeled characters at the fictional
luxury resort Jennifer Coolidge is the
only cast member to reprise her role
from season one but we got some new cast
member information
Megan Fahey who is Sutton on the bold
place the Bold type who is a toaster
like that's so important you know like
I've actually hung out with her twice
she's the funnest girl like I'm obsessed
I actually have her phone number like
not me having someone like on the white
lotus's phone number you know it's like
me having Jennifer coolidge's phone
number not you I'm so excited like I
miss Sutton every day and she's a really
good actress she said she's a good
actress she was such a great TV
character the show ended prematurely too
such a great show oh it's White Lotus
season two I'm excited for sorry I'll
talk about the Bold type no I know and
then I'm saying comma yeah and this is a
great like next step for her and her
queer like I feel like she's on her way
now to being like major major actress
major Stars she deserves all of it who
else is in it um Aubry Plaza which I
believe we reported on yeah she's like
I'm not like an Aubry Plaza girl I feel
like this will be the thing I feel like
people love her from that show that she
was on was it Parks and Rec yeah and I
obviously never got into that so I just
feel like she popped up and like I don't
know her Theo James so we obviously love
F Murray Abraham I'm more of an F Scott
Fitzgerald girl Adam DeMarco I don't
know any of these people me neither
maybe you would know their fatches yeah
Adam DeMarco sounds like a fox I might
remember hmm I'm saying oh you you don't
know I mean you don't know my brain so
let me say I know your brain I'm of
course I know that guy what's he from
Comic-Con
you don't know him no I don't know him
I'm kidding
um well hopefully this will make a star
you know Sydney Sweeney was on it when
like not that many people knew her like
Euphoria hadn't blown up in the way that
it has now so like she was still really
she was from something else though
because people already really liked her
what was her breakout role is it not
Euphoria I don't think it's Euphoria
um I feel like she wasn't like we are
the Millers or something
she's in like uh she was in Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood oh but I don't think
in a big enough role that people fell in
love with her but I just remember Zach
knew who she was and I don't think he
watches Euphoria well she just got cast
in a big Marvel thing by the way so like
she's really she's on her way to being
like Megan Fox Madam Webb got it I never
saw it no that's the Marvel thing oh
yeah oh so it was just announced and
it's like a Michael Bay movie so it's
literally Megan she's like following
Megan Fox's Michael Bay was Transformers
and that was Megan Fox's like thing yeah
that's exciting so she's I feel like who
do you think is Zendaya was like already
famous so like obviously Zendaya is the
most famous one from Euphoria but who'd
you say is a breakout star before you
Sydney Sweeney yeah because I don't
watch Euphoria and I only know her
Zendaya Jacob alordi yeah and Jacob Lori
and Zendaya were famous before yeah and
I know there's other people and you talk
about them sometimes but like mod Apatow
oh I didn't know she was on it oh yeah I
think
Judd yeah Judd's daughter you know I
know who she is but I didn't really
realize she was on it and she was famous
before and yeah no it doesn't count like
the nepotism is that an appetism that
bothers you
no I never thought about it no because
like they're just like family business I
know and like I feel like her and her
sister are both actors um and anytime
I've seen them and stuff it's like their
dad's movie so it's like yeah you want
like sure that's your dad like he's
obviously gonna put you in your movie
and they're both extremely talented and
I feel like they they actually like did
really good jobs in their dad's films
like they were both in this is 40. yeah
um that it doesn't bother me nepotism
for me is like so like I'm so choosy
with who I'm gonna get all bent out of
shape over agree but then it also so
is about are they good at the job you
know like maybe they have more doors
open for them but like is it a pleasure
to watch and I just want to say there's
like a lot of celebrity Offspring and
like a lot of them don't go on to do
what Gwyneth Paltrow did right when
Oscars create billion dollar companies
right
and even like look at you know look at
the bald ones like Haley is arguably the
most famous Offspring but like for a
while like we all knew Ireland and like
Ireland's on Tick Tock now like Haley
doesn't come from the most famous parent
right but like and it's not for lack of
trying that Ireland is not as famous as
and Ireland's mom is
Kim Basinger yeah so like she had like
the most the biggest platform to begin
with and like still Haley so you're
right like just because you have it
doesn't mean you have it right it
doesn't mean you have it in the bag yeah
you still have to work obviously not as
hard as everyone else but still pretty
good yeah but then I'm sure they'll say
I have to work even harder to prove
myself that I'm worthy of being here I I
don't agree with that I can't say you
know same but I just don't think that's
the truth that's not a good rebuttal to
nepotism it's like no for sure but like
once I got there I had to work even like
the door was open for me but then once I
got through the door like I had to work
even harder to prove myself I really
don't like that line of thinking I think
people who are like benefit benefactors
of nepotism should stop saying it
because nepotism doesn't bother me that
much but if you're gonna go over here
and like start explaining yourself and
like be a little delusional like come on
like let's be real yeah it's not
happening
um so through the past five you
certainly needed to know them but what
you really need to know are Jackie and I
thought on the season finale of House of
the Dragon episode 10 aired last night
we're gonna talk about it in the TV
recap which is brought to you and
sponsored by bowling branch
so bowling Branch obviously is the
Betting Company the Betting Company of
all my dreams
um I'm a as opposed to the rat of all
your dreams yeah yeah so at home I'm a
bowling Branch girl my entire house is
bowling branch and that's why I love
staying at Jackie's because pretty much
nothing has changed all my betting is
bowling Branch we have the same waffle
throw blanket on our beds the one that I
have in my guest room here is cream and
the one I have at home is blue to go
with my Coastal grandmother Vibe
um I feel like cream sauce oh for sure
the bedding from Bowling Ranch is simply
everything of the sort I feel like a lot
of you actually have trusted us and
ordered bowling branch in the past and
we appreciate you trusting us and we
know you're super happy with the results
The Collection that Jackie and I both
have is the signature hem sheets from
Bowling Branch it's their best selling
set for a good reason it's made from the
highest quality threads for a superior
softness and a better night's sleep over
25 000 people have raved um in their
reviews online they're buttery they're
cozy and they're super breathable making
them perfect for every season so they're
luxury sheets for every bed and any
Decor because their sheets come in nine
colors and they fit all different types
of mattress says whatever your size is
you'll feel the difference the moment
you lie down and best of all is that
bowling Branch gives you a 30 night
risk-free trial with free shippings and
Returns on all orders also we love
bowling Branch because they're on a
mission that helps you sleep better at
night they have fully traceable
end-to-end sorting that ensures the
quality of their sheets and ensures that
they're all being made in a socially
responsible way the first hundred
percent organic fair trade certified
bedding company and they're made using
90 less water than conventional
production with zero pesticides and
toxic chemicals try the sheets that will
make fall the coziest season this year
and get 15 off your first set of sheets
and free shipping when you use promo
code toast at bowlingbranch.com that's
bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-dranch.com promo code toast
at bowl endbranch.com that code is
toastbowlingbranch.com great all right
season finale was like a little
lackluster especially compared to
episode nine like I thought at least you
know we knew that there was going to be
a war you know it's beginning Civil War
for the crown I actually think it was
the exact same as episode nine it was
all just the maneuvering episode nine
was about how the high Towers maneuvered
in the wake of the Kingston it was very
exciting like they actually did stuff
like the the turn uh the Dragonstone
people didn't start maneuvering until 45
minutes in and then nothing happened
because that kid died right like both
had a big ending and without those big
endings really nothing major would have
happened in the episodes right Jace died
that was like obviously what what it was
and it was so sad oh sorry oh my God
yellow Sarah
luceris died he um he was eaten he was
eating he was like a little young to be
like out doing some tasks like he wasn't
ready he wasn't ready especially I mean
we didn't know that you know amond the
one-eyed Mulligan was gonna be and I
didn't realize there was such a big
difference in the size of their dragons
me neither and I was curious about that
I mean I know that Eamon stole his
dragon from Damon's first wife yeah
second
second wife yet once she died um he like
snuck down and stole her but why was
hers so much bigger because she's older
and that was so they get a dragon yeah
they grow with you as they said in the
war room that they have three adult
dragons so the uh I just thought like
adult men like better training they
don't um grow like with you necessarily
but like if she started with him as a
baby and then she's a grown woman he
grew too yeah no that makes sense we
were dragons
um that the kids have got it the scene
of her giving birth I feel like was like
so triggering like it was terrible it
was so horrible
um so it was like a stillbirth right
yeah like that was really upset I don't
know why that had to happen no I know
and like even if it did have to happen
like I don't feel like they really had
to show like that graphic like I
actually think like if you've been
through something like that like it's
immensely triggering like it was it was
a lot like and I'm not like I have no
like experience tied to that like I was
triggered you know yeah no it was a lot
they're obsessed with the house of
dragon like having traumatic birth
scenes No I know and like as as a woman
like it's a lot and like I'm never even
given birth like I need them to stop
yeah
um and so and then Rainier I lost two
children in one episode right
let's talk about the choke because that
was really hard for me I was when I saw
it I was thinking of you because you
have been a demon apologist this whole
time there's nothing that he could do
that you couldn't explain away and then
he came literally for neighboring or his
throat and I was just like what do you
think about Damon now so I am still
searching for an excuse so I'm like I'm
searching for like adjusted like I like
there's a reason obviously because Damon
would like never do that so
um I am out here making excuses for the
violence and that's wrong of me but I'm
that's what I'm doing so if someone
could sound off in the comments and
provide a good a good reason why I
shouldn't be mad like I'm desperately
searching for that yeah Rainier should
have sent Damon with Luke yeah of course
like and I think like he was you know in
the beginning of the episode like
expressing some of his insecurities so
she thought this would like Empower him
a little did she know it killed him and
so I think she was just like eager to
give him like some sort of courage and
purpose and it ended up being the thing
that killed him
it was horrible and they couldn't have
known known amond was there I [ __ ]
hate aemond like
and
they were at Baratheon right is that who
that was that guy who couldn't read yeah
love that hey Michelle Lee Michelle
um
like I just feel like baratheons honor
their Oaths like I I feel that but I'm
thinking about the baratheons of you
know right Robert was a literal usurper
oh right but Stannis wasn't he a good
guy no
Stannis was I don't know about a good
guy I just consider like baratheons to
be like really close with the Starks and
like the Starks honor their word of
course yeah but also this is 200 years
before
but it runs in their blood in my opinion
I don't know baratheons I think can go
either way and like Robert breathy and
like sat on the throne that really
wasn't his to sit on why was he the king
why did Lannister Starks and targaryens
go to war and big old Robert said on the
throne and so true after all that we're
gonna end up with Robert right you know
and like Robert brought Down The House
of the Dragon like this big dog yeah
someone's not adding up like just like
his ancestor before him on the throne
who couldn't read right right right
um he did look like Robert so I thought
that was a good I thought that was good
casting too
um so like to be honest I feel like
nothing really happened except Rainier
is now activated yeah of course because
it like when amend killed luceroes like
he started the war officially so and he
knew it when he flew away and he wasn't
like super pleased with himself that
wasn't the outcome he was looking for he
wanted to [ __ ] around and then he found
that out and that's what happens it was
really sad because like
her kids are like pjoms like they're so
sweet and like they're not evil and
they're they don't look for problems
like he's just doing what his mom said
messenger and of course Eamon had to
follow him into the sky like that was so
upsetting yeah
how did they find out so quick that
their son had died
well one he doesn't come home and it's
quick trip to
where yeah but like that doesn't assume
that he's dead and I don't know maybe
Eamon told someone yeah or like and
maybe it wasn't so quick maybe it was a
few days yeah yeah that's true maybe
they were looking for him and they found
like do you want to hear something crazy
like you're really not gonna like like
we get season two in 2024. I heard like
that's insane I know how the [ __ ] are we
supposed to remember what happened I
know they do previously on but like
we're gonna have to re-watch
no I think we'll be able to remember
this season it's just like now
everyone's activated for battle it's a
battle for the throne yeah but like it's
hard to remember like who's who who's
related to who whose [ __ ] name is
probably recast more [ __ ] while we're
gone
um so it was let's look at it at a
glance you know this first new season of
the prequel I thought it was excellent
excellent and it really is the lead up
to what this show is about which is the
Civil War in-house Targaryen yeah it was
excellent and now we see how we got from
A to Z right and like how Rainier like
really would be best fit as Queen and
like up in someone away because like
when he choked her like up until then he
was being such a patron like really
taking control like maybe a little bit
too much control but like she was giving
birth and he does have like a proclivity
towards violence right but like he was
the one who like he started the
coronation like I love that guy who came
with a crown like obsessed with him
um and like you know some men might be
intimidated by being married to the
queen of the Seven Kingdoms like no he
was like down he got on his knee first
he could do it again he was Prince but
Prince oh
he literally was I thought you were like
making like he's like Prince Philip no
no he played Prince Philip so he knows
what it's like yeah to be second fiddle
love that yeah but he has I don't think
he want I mean sure everyone wants to be
king but I think now he's very assured
in his role of like getting Rainier on
the throne and he can
protect her yeah yeah
it's good stuff and I was just happy to
see Damon because we didn't even see him
last episode if maybe for five seconds
he didn't even say a word
oh and rainy's and Lord cordless is back
and Lord Corliss like they're good peeps
like they are they take their time but
they get they always do the right thing
yeah as you should yeah they are good
because I also understand them like this
is not our [ __ ] problem right leave
us alone in their heart of hearts they
know that those boys are not related to
them and so now who sits on the drift
marked Throne no right and who marries
their dog their granddaughter
she has more Sons but at least now they
have like a like a pawn almost because
like having a kid to marry off when you
have like a sufficient
uh inheritance like is upon like you can
make a good marriage make an ally so at
least they have that like it's a
positive thing yeah but yeah and they
were like all into each other it's like
that was sad because Ted they were all
so excited like oh he's walking over to
I know to the other it was sad at least
Jason the older one are still gonna go
it we think all right
maybe like Jace well no Jace is the heir
after Venera
but she still has three more kids yeah
but like they're super young yeah but
still they always are making yeah
inappropriate matches and it's for one
day right okay sure so that's the TV
recap that is our show um thank you guys
so much for listening to the toast the
Monday Morning Show where we deliver the
past five stories you need to show
everybody Friday on YouTube so for
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as
podcasts anywhere podcast can be found
so at Spotify iTunes Stitcher public
radio I got radiocast box all the places
so every listen to podcast find us the
toes leave five star review about a
beautiful sounding smart we are hope you
guys have an incredible Monday and we'll
see you tomorrow on Tuesday's episode
we'll see you tomorrow might be up a
little bit later because we have a
family function we have a family
function but um it will be up
nonetheless yes it will be later thank
you for reminding me
um have a blessed day we love ya love
you bye love you bye